foreign
all right for people joining this live
stream we are talking about historical
Geographic functionality a Muslim
language
this is a long awaited as far as I'm
concerned at least design review
of this functionality about things that
are from often the distant past all
right so let's get started here
so first
this is this new this dated construct
here
uh no
um I am only remind putting this as an
example of how the
polygons in historical country already
work
the issue I was trying to signal with
the with including historical countries
in the jio functions
is that the Geo functions
work by
allowing the user to you to make use of
the geographic shapes assigned to
different entities but the issue with
them we've already got a problem here
why didn't that work
well first of all I think you need to
put a list around 261.
oh
but missing not applicable is
unconvincing
I mean that that is correct that's
granularity of a year well let's do
granularity
so that worked but the century did not
what should it do missing not applicable
is not a very good answer there
I mean what is it if it's not not
applicable
well
go ahead ah I think uh with the Geo
functions what we try to to do with a
lower granularity date objects is to in
this case return a Time series of the
polygons during that will be one long
time periods that would be wonderful
well but that that seems like it could
lead to issues though because
well for example you know if we had I
mean if we had more granular data at
some point right now everything is a
year but suppose you know during World
War II or something we have data that's
you know at the month level or something
then if you asked for if you gave it a
year granularity thing it would then
suddenly start giving a Time series I I
feel like it's sort of
it's very unpredictable you know it's
better if it sort of like Returns the
head you expect
yes yeah I agree with that I think the
right thing to do here is if you feed a
date object you should do it on a single
thing if you fit a date interval then
you are asking explicitly for a range to
that point
okay but we need to decide what to do I
mean maybe it just returns in the center
of the century or I don't know what but
anyway the standard thing is usually the
beginning we have a tendency to select
the beginning of a date
object when we can only handle an insta
okay
but since I was was um starting off
describing something and I kind of came
off sorry
so please continue
okay uh the issue is
the surgical polygons is that they have
the with historical countries I'm sorry
uh
is that
unlike geographical entities that have
only
a single shape assigned to them
they have many shapes that change over
time
indeed uh
and then
we then have to condense that data in
order to make calculations
that's how I understand but so let's be
specific here I mean what
okay you're going to show stuff about
geovariance or what yes uh
that we defined three possible Geo
variants
one that is a Time series of volumes
another that is the group a Geo Group
of all the polygons assigned to an
entity
as you can see in that example
okay although that doesn't record when
no I just records what exactly right
and if you look below
the maximum expansion Geo variant is the
largest
Geographic shape or polygon assigned to
the to the entity
also does not really record the date
okay
uh
okay yes and part of the discussion now
will be what will be the best name for
this your variance and I don't pick up
the convincing but yeah okay
and what will be the default also
yes right uh I put there an uh an
example
because when we are talking about for
instance the the first geofunction
that uh that we are considering Geo
within Q
yep that that function is pretty
straightforward in with geographical
entities
but it could be
yeah let me just get an understanding
okay so I understand the first point is
there are three different possible
things there is
well there's actually four things right
because there's there's this specific
there's the form of the gallic Empire on
a specific date
there's the time series but for the
gallic Empire as a whole
throughout its history there is the time
series there's the collection of
polygons that we happen to have in our
database
and there's the maximum extension which
might not have been contemporary you
know in other words they might have
extended to the South and then lost the
southern territory and extend it to the
north but maximum expansion presumably
is the essentially the convex Hull of
where that that Empire reached is that
correct wait no no that's just the point
at which it had the greatest area
you don't want to show a polygon that's
that never existed
that will be the unit of physio group
right it's much more useful to do the
maximal buy of Geo Group comma Geo area
than it is to do some Union okay all
right okay like if you do unions you'll
find things that are like totally
unrecognizable because you'd be like oh
I didn't know that you know for 10
minutes uh you know Rome controlled
whatever and and it'll be some weird
looking map okay fair enough yes exactly
and as Francisco told Geo Group
S as a kind of Union when talking about
the jio functions
as it is a collection of all the
polygons if we say for instance data
point belongs to the Geo Group is the
same to saying that it belongs to the
union except it's just a list I mean how
would I take that list and actually make
the region Union of it can I do that
can really do it right now you'd have to
boundary discretize Graphics each of the
polygons actually sorry you have to Geo
grid position each of the polygons
boundary discretized Graphics region
Union
and then getting it back into well you
do some mesh Primitives things so it's a
big mess basically yeah there isn't a
super clean way to do it right now
okay
there's no geo-region Union type thing
no no the other
sorry go ahead I would just saying no no
okay
um I was gonna ask what the relationship
I mean is it intentional that this is
using the same name as Geo Group because
Geo Group is a symbol that we have
yes if you rub your group around this
then Geographics will treat this as a as
a Unity
baby it just seems like it you know it
doesn't seems like for a Geo Group you
sort of maybe would expect something
yeah I don't think I don't think yeah I
I agree with that it was just this idea
of treating it together okay but so if I
say Geographics here then I will get the
Union right and you wouldn't need the
Geo Group in order for the Geographics
to work of course
okay although actually you can see it
didn't I mean of course it it didn't
actually compute the union which you can
see because the the opacities
right
so one polygon seems to be like twice
there
so so one quick question is why are
these what's the argument for using
these as Geo variants as opposed to
having them as at least some of them as
alternative uh you know uh properties
like for example maximum extent and and
the dates and stuff like that that seems
to make sense with like qualifiers so it
makes sense instead of like geovariant
or something like that which I think
usually align with qualifiers but
something like Geo Group seems like it
could maybe even be its own property I
agree I agree let's let's let's just
look down further here and then let's
loop back to this okay I just want to
get a sense of what the whole story is
um okay so Geo within Q
yes
um with a geographic entity is pretty
straightforward uh
in the case of
to
in the case of a polygon and a point or
an or an entity that represents a point
it returns if the point
is inside yeah okay so the question you
want to ask is was this point ever in
the gallic Empire a single point was it
ever there
and that's one question and then
I mean and then
I think it's it's messier than that
because it's stuffed like okay was the
you know was the modern state of Italy
ever within Rome well it's like well
they were never contemporaneous but if I
pick my default polygons with them which
is probably the maximum extent you know
then the answer is yes but you know so
so maybe we're just comparing them at
their maximal extents but then if I say
was the Gaelic empire ever in Rome well
these were contemporaneous things and so
it's sort of uh you know
this this becomes more complicated I
think well so the question is is geo
with NQ if we think about it in space
time
is it you know these these empires have
an extent in space-time
which you know something we've discussed
in the past actually representing you
know the space-time history of one of
these things
and then deal with NQ we have to Define
what on Earth is it is it you know
projecting in time projecting in space
you know what the heck is it because we
got this blob in space-time right
what does deal within Q represent with
respect to space-time does that make
sense that question
yep
go ahead
so let me say just one thing so the idea
here was that we have several
possibilities so we named them by
geovanians and then we let the various
functions do whatever they want to do
with the various your your volumes
and at the very end there is the
question of which one is the one that we
are going to use by default
I'm not convinced I think we're being a
little bit too naive here so so I mean I
think I think there is a space-time
interpretation of all these behaviors
here right so so for example if you know
the maximum expansion is just a single
slice
uh you know the the Geo Group is well
actually maybe it's just a slice that
sort of extended maximally you take a
single slice and then you sort of
project it out through all time and the
same the Geo Group
and then you know the dated polygon is
instead some weird Blobby thing that you
know doesn't extend infinitely in time
and so on exactly right and that's why
we wanted them as your variants somehow
because we wanted to be able to
to reference them in these functions
and not simply properties so I think
they are useful as properties maybe to
but as your variants were needed because
we wanted to to reference them and this
is one of the designs possible designs
right because another way would be to
have a different set of functions that
will take into account the dated
components let's just see down to the
end here okay so
foreign
you're asking so this is a geo so this
is defining essentially a space-time
object
yes and this is now asking but you see
because because here's a question right
how about you know is D-Day
within you know what does that mean
because what is geo with NQ asking a
time question as well as asking a space
question or not
you see what I'm saying because it could
be the case we could be asking is D-Day
within the geographic region of the
Roman Empire
clearly I think I think that's what the
Geo variants were supposed and maybe
this data here are supposed to do
right I mean if you say date what was it
dated polygon then it is asking the time
question as well if you say I think I
think any of the others it's not asking
the time right okay so so basically what
we're saying is if we if we summarize
this well I need to save this sorry I'm
just trying to say and I'm guessing
correct me if I'm wrong I'm guessing
that the dated is also not asking the
time questions effectively Computing the
union of of all the polygons between 100
and 200. by the way I assume somebody
has looked at the previous notes that we
had on this topic
you have haven't you
um
have you looked at the previous notes
that we have on this topic uh yeah 2018
and 2019.
which is an awfully long time ago
disappointed that it's such an
unbelievably long time
okay
do we not have meetings about this since
then
I don't think so
I I think we covered a bit last year
so more than a year has been yeah
okay
okay
all right so let's let's come back again
um I just want to get a sense of what
you're looking at here
temporal entities
uh yes these are still in development
um what they do is only identify them by
time and not geography
inside the one
yeah
so this is a separate proposal so in
case we just wanted your function so
just just take care of the of the
geographical part and then we want to
treat
um the the time and I mean this
shouldn't be temporal maybe dated I
don't know uh and then the time part of
the of the entities in a separate way
it's not it's not too too overcharge the
geographical functions these two last
ones were not meant to to be included
sorry
okay
so
all right so let's come back here let's
let's let's zoom out a little bit to the
bigger picture here so I mean every
what do we have we have
you know we have space time
Geographic entities
okay
um
defined by certain
uh anchor points so to speak which are
the the slices so just just so I
understand here let me pick one of these
uh just for fun just so we understand
what we got
um
what's one of these that has a
reasonably large number of of polygons
um I I just can somebody help me by
taking this and uh I just want to draw
the stack of these things so something
like Roman Republic usually has like
hundreds okay all right so let's let's
say um
uh
okay can somebody help me with the code
I just just so we have a concept here I
want to just draw this as a big stack
Through Time
did you understand even a geostack or
just a shield stack I I mean a stack
where I've got the positions I don't
care about projections or anything I
just want to draw them in a 3D
you know a 3D stack here
how would I do that
oh no go ahead probably you would do
you'd map geogrid position over those to
project them which you have to do and
then
um
maybe you have to boundary discretize
Graphics that I'm not sure
if you just want like an opacity stack
thing you can just say geographics of
them though you have to provide a
projection so it's your great position
okay let's just do let's just do the the
geographics of them just for to get
something even though it's not really
what I wanted but but just because
because what I'm really wanting is
to make the point
so let's just make this
okay fine not great but but you can
probably reduce the opacity and make it
a little bit better but yeah okay
all right well each one actually what I
probably could do is to say
um a map thread on this of a style
uh that's what's what's a good color
let's say map
um
if you're trying to do a color you know
color over time they're all going to be
on top of each other it's going to be
unreadable I know I know I know but I'm
gonna have a pass today
Style
uh
style of hash comma color data
Hue of um of hue or first of hash two
comma
um first of hash two divided by yeah 20
or something 30 whatever divided by the
length of percent 10
um comma uh let's see what I want 1 1.1
or something is that right
um
okay whatever not great but let's um
it is what it is
um well one thing of course is that also
because this isn't using the time series
stuff you know the the periods that
lasted 100 years are counting the same
in this plot as the periods that lasted
two
yes which is right there
okay so in these geopositions even
though geopositions can also have times
in them we're not including those here
is that correct
yes that's correct because we could
include them
could we mean the initial link stands
for example
perhaps yes perhaps I mean in other
words these things each one of these in
space-time
defines a certain space like slice
right and then they're stacked in time
and we are implicitly making certain
sort of stepping assumptions or not
about what happens in between the
space-like surfaces that we've defined
right right yes it's implicitly an
interpolation of order zero yes
well I don't even know what order zero
means that is I don't know whether it
steps up or what it does with respect to
when the step happens
this is what I'm saying does it does it
assume it assumes that it is a hold
until the next one comes in basically is
that correct yes it holds the position
until next one okay
so
what we're asking then
see I have this feeling that
we should be keeping the time
information here
because
without that and that Geo within Q for
example
should even be asking I mean should be
capable or perhaps it's a variant of
jail with NQ should be capable of asking
how do these overlap in space-time
as well as just how do these overlap in
space because both are valid questions
am I making sense
you're never going to get around the
fact that there are two different
questions right but I think at least in
this proposal there is some stuff about
exactly that
okay
well okay overlap in space
overlap in space time
overlap in time those are all different
questions right I know whether there are
any other
okay and that's that's still within Cube
but now what are the other kinds of
functions that we have here what's
geo-identified geo-identifiers asking
I see what country
okay but but now if I say hold on if I
say
geo-identify
uh
Eiffel Tower
why does it need to say entity
historical country it doesn't need the
word entity there right
um you have to be clear to make it clear
that it was an entity type but yes it's
none yet okay all right so in this case
Eiffel Tower doesn't have a date so save
you with it
so it's done through all time that's the
point it's doing it this is a um
this is
okay so both entities and geo with NQ in
principle both entities are space-time
blobs
so now for each entity and and maybe I'm
coming to your geovariant idea each
entity so in other words natively
each entity
is a blob in space-time
but what you're effectively proposing is
but you could have
a geovariant
that defines a projection
into space or into time
yes something like that
yeah or to find a different region in
space-time
it's an instruction to the geofunctions
about how they should be interpreted
I understand that but a way to think
about it is we're taking the blob in
space time and we're simply looking at
the the silhouette of that blob in the
sense not quite the silhouette but like
the maximum extension thing is I don't
know quite what that is it's not a
silhouette a silhouette would be the
combination of all you know all that
sort of extents and so on but it'd be
like you take the maximum extent and you
just project it out to you know infinite
future and infinite past like it's okay
right but you see there's another
question that you're not addressing here
which is
um has this point
was this point ever in the Roman Empire
what what do you mean by point because
Battle of Antioch is a point because it
has a date but Eiffel Tower is a line
okay was the spatial point
was this special Point ever in the Roman
Empire
right so that means that is a silhouette
question about the Roman Empire that's
not just about the maximum stent of the
Roman Empire that's about you know any
one of these tentacles reaching out into
the Caspian Sea as it shouldn't
um
well in that case it almost doesn't
matter I mean as long as you don't you
know it doesn't matter whether you're
looking at the union Geo Empire or the
Geo Empire projected to old time or you
know as long as you're not looking at
maximum extent that will give you the
same answer in that case
fine but I mean that that's okay
that's ever in the Roman Empire which is
different from was this spatial point
in the maximum extent Roman Empire
and another question would be
was does this space-time blob
was that you know were the Hanging
Gardens of Babylon always in the
Babylonian Empire or did they exist
after the Babylonian Empire had fallen
well actually the simpler case would be
the Battle of Antioch cases just does
this serve spacio temporal point you
know actual point in space time in the
Roman Empire
right okay
foreign
okay
so let's let's take a look at this then
and so now
geo-identify
let's see which what are the various
functions
what is Geo entities what is that
your entities searches for every entity
that is contained
within uh given reference for instance
these are all the military conflicts in
the Roman Republic
if we want it with this methodology to
do all the entities that especially were
included inside the Roman Republic we
could use the ideal group
a horrible name but I understand the
concept
um
okay so so what you're trying to Define
here I'm beginning to understand this
is you want a Geo variant that means
uh basically
the
s
spatial region
really what you want
oh my gosh so wait a minute we've got
the spatial region
ever cut you know the union spatial
region
covered by The Entity
the spatial region unioned over time
special region Union over time is that
one that that's one of the one of every
point that was ever in the Roman Empire
every Point ever in
Empire X
okay
the next thing we want
is this question of a timed
so okay so entities
entities can intrinsically
have positions and times
how they can have positions
times positions plus times
okay so for example
the Eiffel Tower could have
I mean it's an interesting point of
things that still exist and have an
infinite future potentially it has a
position and it could have a time but it
doesn't have a time right now
correct
then we could tag is on here yes Alan is
here we could like tag buildings with
you know they started at this time and
they go into the future
well we have
construction start and completion dates
and destruction dates in cases where we
know things have been destroyed in a lot
of cases right right right but I mean we
have we have properties we could use to
define the likely lifespan of a of a
thing so and that originally you'd want
to have you know some sort of
standardized start date you know you
classify you know if it's a building
property this is the you know if it's a
building this is the property you used
to denote its start date and this is the
properties you know it's end date and
that would define it
just to throw one wrinkle into that that
gets potentially a little bit
complicated too because you have a lot
of buildings that you know the we have a
construction start date and a
construction end date and this the space
between those points could be
years or many years and you might want
to you might be interested in you know
other things in space-time close to the
thing when they first started
construction but you might also be
interested in only knowing about the
finished building
yup so that's a that's essentially an
entity variant yeah
of whether the building was finished or
not
you know show this building only when
finished now
um in that old temporal
um temporal logic thing that never got
finished Jose which we should come back
to by the way we had a notion of future
Infinity right
which we don't have we have a symbol now
it was introduced for for entities
oh wow cool cool okay
so we have a date we can have a date
interval that says you know somewhat
optimistically the United States was
started at this date and extends into
the internet future
um now you're talking crazy
the
the whatever
um the the
um
Okay so
but
but then we okay so right now the only
entities that a space-time tagged are
historical countries is that a true
statement no no we've also got like
battles and things a space-time tagged
although those are points rather than
extended regions right military
conflicts well well although there are
battles like in World War II and things
there are quote unquote battles that
lasted months
and how do we tag those we have tagging
with date intervals
yes
um
World War II itself obviously has a has
a multi-year extent
so
polygon for that right so yes not well
defined that as a problem but there are
battles that last for a certain amount
of time
and in that case it is they are defined
by a start date and an end date
but I mean in fact we could perfectly
well have the fact that we don't have a
polygon for World War II
is not necessary I mean it's a little
weird because we you know we think of
World War II as being a set of Point hot
spots or battles as opposed to a
thing that involved a an extended area
I think but we could think of it and I
think in I don't know I mean
yeah that's a weird thing isn't it
because most weird stuff you can imagine
I could imagine wanting to ask questions
about World War II that are only about
things that are contemporaneous with it
in time
and not in space
I understand but I mean if you ask the
question
you know take
look here's a question we might ask
um you know
was Crete in World War II
well that makes it sound like you're
asking if it was an actor in World War
II
but yes my mix there
yeah okay fine but I mean I'm sorry
involved in World War II and you can ask
yes was Fiji as a country involved and
was the territory of Fiji a place where
things happened in World War II I I
think that is a hopeless historical
question where it's going to be like uh
you know
it does like one of those things I mean
that's an example that demonstrates why
I don't think you can do this because
because whether or not Fiji was involved
will be the sort of thing where
historians would debate it and they'll
be you know quoting well the king of
Fiji said on this date that you know he
thought X or Y and so that signaled
involvement or something and it's like
you know
good luck but I mean that was that was
the example it's going to bring up with
World War II he's like oh we'll do color
like you know the entire Pacific as in
the war or not like it's just you know
right there could have been a battle in
Antarctica it didn't happen but there
might have been so maybe Antarctica was
in the war
right and so one thing that we could say
here is a country
at least in Fairly modern times has some
legal Declaration of its borders
you know I think
you know in a war people say we're going
to war but they don't say oh you know in
this region of the Pacific is now part
of the theater of war at least I don't
think so I don't think there's any legal
sense in which that's the case at least
historically that was definitely not the
case
I don't think there's any standard for
that I mean certainly the Romans did not
do that
right but they did have okay so
historical countries
have some sense in which they will had
legally defined borders
that is often not the case okay but I
mean in in concept usually not the case
but yeah
but I don't know when when people
started having treaties about those
things probably by the by the 1600s or
something maybe earlier than that I
don't know
there are some Babylonian ones of course
but yes okay fair enough the
um okay but but so now let's come back
here to
what okay let's look at now now that I
have a little bit of a better
understanding what the heck you're
talking about
you are proposing three Geo variants is
that correct
yes
okay
and except you had later at the bottom
you had what's essentially a a date
variant or something or something which
is which is taking a historical country
like like if I want to take
okay let's say this it's basically a
proposal to to to treat the the temporal
part of the date part in a separate way
why doesn't that work
why doesn't I mean to me I don't
understand why should this work date
interval of French second Republic
so this is an idea that we have explored
recently and it is imitating the fact
that the Geo entities
which are those entities responding at
your position to the property position
could and can be used anywhere in in Geo
functions the same thing could happen
for the dated entities in date functions
yes I think so
it would be a matter of agreeing that if
they have a property called date
the date functions will just extract
that date
and maybe more generally they could have
start date and date things but as
brought up earlier there are questions
about you know start your construction
random construction or whatever right
but those are going to be variants which
are like geovariant except that those
are some kind of date variant
right so the opposition asks for six
different properties to the entities
and in order it says oh would you report
something to coordinates I use this if
you didn't return anything from
properties sorry for position
I see okay and we can do the same thing
with these exactly
so and in particular if we ask for date
object of this
we I don't know what we exactly return
we return a start time or something
presumably
right
and they interval with return on
interval if it has a start and end yep
and various variants of that
um
you know right now we have dated as a
qualifier
and and clearly dated we could take
presumably
well dated would override
you know
what the heck would happen if I said the
Battle of Antioch
but I wrap dated around it
would that mean
the remaining properties of the battle
of Antioch like its geolocation
but now projected to a different date
or would it be an error or what would it
mean
yeah I think it's not a restriction
I see so so it might miss in which case
there would be nothing there
well but hold on but if there are
properties in the Battle of Antioch that
are not don't have a date qualifier then
does that mean that those properties
sort of extend infinitely in time so
like you know if you had a building uh
yeah and what color was it it was Green
but of course it might have turned from
green to Red on a certain date
okay let's come back over here
um
and try to understand this so first
thing is the time series now what is
that time series is that a Time series
with polygons inside it or what yes
so if I take that time series and I say
for example
well how about Geo area ah just
Ugg that's not good
so I wouldn't expect go ahead
Geographics understands this but not the
rest of the Geo functions
wait what does Geographics do in the
time series
value so
it's doing the same as with associations
what is that doing why is that arrowed
out here
missing is not a graphics primitive or
directive that's not encouraging
okay so there's a problem there okay the
problem is that for the time series we
are tagging because we don't have time
series that can have a limit we are
adding an extra element for the last
date with missing value
because if not the time series assumes
that it goes uh infinity to the
to the Future
so if you get values of this you will
get a missing as last value
is there not a reason I
I'm thinking about this is there not a
reason to have the last polygon repeat
at the end date it's better to have this
missing
uh what do you mean by last Apollo so so
how we how can we differentiate if they
don't go today so the problem is that
time series doesn't have any options say
okay the time series spans between this
date and this date
right but what happens if you're outside
of those States doesn't by the way I
really hate the fact that these dates
are not granular correctly we really
should just go and fix that every
country about water we have is just to
the year let's just make it granular to
the year can we do that please uh yes
they are not granulated to the year all
of them
so modern countries have granularity to
up-to-day
you guys are capable of going in and
figuring out the granularity and putting
it in please do it just gonna look silly
otherwise
right yes we have discussed this with a
Time series Tim right but I mean but but
it's not time series it's a question of
of the data for these countries
kind of have different granularities
between the start an ending point yeah
but that's a limitation in Time series
so that's something for the time series
developers to to fix okay but you should
have this what does time series do does
it conform them or what does it do if
you feed it something with
differentiarities of dates
I think it's just projecting everything
to Absolute times at the moment
fine but that's okay but at least we
won't get silly stuff here with well I
think it'll still display in the time
series box as as January 1st because
it'll be projecting it to the absolute
time but it but it seems like it's
useful anyway for the dates to have the
right granularities elsewhere
arnode who seems unable to actually
speak an audio in the audio channel is
commenting that it would be nice to be
able to make videos from these things so
you talk a lot about space time and
videos are a great way to uh you know
so the question is can animation video
what is the workflow to go from these
things to an animation video given that
we now have animated time series time I
mean time series off a bunch of polygons
right I think are that they're full
polygons for the Roman Empire here we do
have a marketing example of that
precisely yeah you know if there's an
argument that we should introduce a Time
series video
do I think you just have to make sure
it's it's a little unclear because
I would expect it that you'd give it a
Time series that spans 10 seconds and
then it gives you a 10 second video
indeed right right yeah
it would be a very very long video
um okay but but but maybe it has a
second argument which is its spanning
time or something yeah this is the thing
I'll put a link in the chat to a video
and I'm not sure if you want to take a
video just like it
yeah yeah with slideshow video and and
with the you know the dated Roman Empire
thingies
okay so this is made with using
slideshow slideshow video and uh
right and and just but but this is equal
time for every polygon not it's five
years each year per frame
and it's four four frames per second
so 20 years per second I think no that's
not right no but I understand it but
what you did was you sampled
the polygons of the Roman Empire every
five years or whatever and then you
showed the result of the slideshow video
exactly that's a good thing to do
um
I think I've actually done the same
maybe with animation video where you
just you know you make the T range from
you know
you know one to two hundred and then you
just do take that time series and say of
braces t
right okay but but so let's come back
here
um
that's got to be easy to do basically
but but now what you're saying here
oh gosh
okay this time series on the termination
of the time series this that's screwy
and we need to deal with it and we can't
have a missing hanging out there
so I don't quite understand your issue
your issue before arnode was was talking
about it was was a Time series which
ends in a three
at this time
doesn't it just end then that's the end
of the time series it has nothing more
to say not like it holds the three
forever more the point is the last
polygon you have for the Roman Empire
might be in you know
370 or you know but but then you have to
you know but then your end date for the
Roman Empire is I don't know 376 or
something or whatever and so you have to
uh uh
you know
you wanted to say when you ask for
what's the polygon for the Roman Empire
in 372 so that it turns that 371 it
doesn't say oh you're outside the time
series
I understand so I don't quite understand
how time series versus events series I
don't understand and we don't have
anybody from that group and maybe we can
have another one of these meetings that
includes people from the time series
group
um because they must have a way of
defining I mean it's very much like list
step plot or something of you know
you've got a value does it extend
forwards backwards middle whatever it is
right so time series should have a way
of saying this value is being stated at
this time but extends over the center
ball
does it not have any such mechanism
I mean so what I would be thinking is
what really should be happening is that
polygon from 372 that really extends to
376 should really have a date interval
associated with it that every polygon
here should have a date interval
associated with it yeah guys I think
time Series has these as properties
where you can get the start date the end
date and you can get the values it's you
know all of that stuff is sort of done
with properties in Time series
my guess is that it's an important
property of Time series that it kind of
assumes that that the times are like
instance or like at the time you know
like I think in the end the data
probably has to get into a form like
that although maybe there should be some
ways of inputting data you know look
what this is is something between event
series and time series time series is
defining a function as a function of
time that happens to be where it is an
interpolation of certain values sample
at certain specific times event series
is it only happens you know the
earthquake only happens at these moments
and nothing's happening in between and
what we're defining here is a third case
which is a basically a union of
intervals I think
and I think the proper thing to have
done here is to have an empty polygon at
the end so because we are setting each
interval by its beginning
the final should be just an antibody not
a missing
okay and the Geographics would know what
to do with an empty polymer
but what would happen between the date
of the last polygon that was stated and
the actual end of the empire
it's that it's the last polygon the last
non-empty polygon right because it's
already using some interpolation thing
where you basically just say use
whatever the most recent previous
polygon was but but actually sorry a
problem maybe with the empty polygon
would be if you had that time series and
you want to do something like show me
the area as a function of time and you
know map Geo area over it you're going
to have these weird it collapses to zero
at the end it's a hack
we need a better solution I mean it
really should just have the data extends
to the end of the Empire and then we say
no more
then it shouldn't just go to zero for
example at the end of the Empire well
then that was my question is why why not
have the last thing you know you have
the last real polygon at you know 470
and you say the Empire ends at 476. why
don't you just have that last 470
polygon reappear at 476.
right that way the you know the mapping
Jew area would work the you know you can
imagine that well this was its polygon
five minutes before it collapsed and so
this is a reasonable polygon to give for
476. I mean clearly that would be
you know the barbarians were were
invading and it wasn't really correct
but the question is whether we think
that's the least of the evils
to show it it really was at its full
extent
and then the barbarians made it all
collapse I mean the points were already
saying in any of these cases we're
already saying if you ask him for
75.9 we're still saying oh it looked
like this where we're giving the 470
polygon so it seems reasonable to just
still show that maybe slightly wrong
polygon for the last date too it's a bit
of a hack but yes I agree it's probably
the least of the evils
Bob and our live streams asking can we
specify whether we're defining the
western or Byzantine Empires is the
continuation of the Roman Empire I
believe we have all of that information
right because we're we're defining that
how would we see that we how would we
see that we would see if I say Roman
Empire
I
probably it has a dot dot dot
that asks
whether
it is
the Western Roman Empire the Byzantine
Empire
Etc
so that's that's the first place we get
to see it but is there a way in which we
I mean this is this whole question when
is a country a country
you know we can ask the question you
know
what things have there ever been that
overlapped Constantinople or whatever
that the position of Istanbul whatever
it is
which is a little different again I mean
this is again the space time versus
Space question
um
okay so let's go back over here
uh
we've got
Okay so we've got this time series
which I don't think should be a Geo
variant I think that should just be of
value I what the heck should this be
you know this really wants to be the
space-time
Geo object that's what this really is
it's not a Time series time series is
yet something different
this could be data at all for example
yeah but I mean this could also be a Geo
Time series
so what would a Geo time series do I
mean
right I mean so far it seems like we've
been using time series as the generic
way of projecting any object in time so
what would a Geo time series do that is
different from what a Time series of
geopolygons or geoponditions were doing
well for example it will be eaten by Geo
functions in a reasonable way in a way
that I don't think time series can be
eaten by geofunctions
why not I mean well maybe it should be
it's being proposed here that it will I
mean my only point would just be that
usually when we introduce a new
construct like this it's because oh
there's some subtle difference between
what a Time series fundamentally
represents and what a Geo time Series
has to represent
but I think there absolutely will be
because I mean in a sense there's
ribbing of the particular polygons we
have and then there's some complicated
interpolation between those polygons
but isn't that already what time series
does I mean you have limited things and
maybe there's interpolation between them
okay but but there's okay so fine but so
is there a possibility then that Geo
Within
for example
could jail with NQ then deal with NQ
would have to take a Time series
that's what's proposed in the notebook
is it yes wasn't it oh no sorry maybe it
was just taking a Geo variant yeah it's
different but it actually could take a
Time series yeah that has to work
as opposed to just the symbolic
geovariant
it would have to be Geo within queue
and then and then what what it would be
very bizarrely was you could do geo with
NQ of a Time series
one time series and then another time
series
see what I'm saying
and that would then have the space time
we'll be asking a space-time question
does that make sense
yep
now can we make that work
uh yes uh currently it now works in the
internal functions
it's it is not yet exposed
okay but let's see whether okay so then
in that case what we're basically saying
is a space-time country is represented
by a Time series
that's what we're saying I don't know
whether we'll get away with that but
that's what we're saying right now
and
uh
okay and that Geo within Q
if it is given a Time series we'll we'll
by default treat that okay so by default
it will treat this thing as a space-time
blob unless it is given a Geo variant
of for example
um well if it's given a dated of this
clearly what should happen is dated of a
Time series
has got to project out the thing for
that particular date
if that makes sense right
that that will be the consistent thing
to do there
make sense guys right yeah and then
there could be a geovariant that says
that takes the time series effectively I
mean it can also take a symbolic object
but it takes the time series
and
it says something like maximum extent
so how far the ovarian only takes
entities it's a it's a modifier of
entities I know I know that but I'm
saying I don't think that's going to
work I don't think that's enough
well I think if we have the time series
we have essentially geometry so we
should use geometric functions to
perform the operation we want but how do
you get maximum extent out of the time
series
well we would need a function to compute
that but your variant sounds strange
apply jio variant to a polygon even
well I'm not necessarily disagreeing
um I mean with this it would turn into a
general purpose and we have like image
measurements which gives you all sorts
of little properties I mean this would
basically turn geovariant into something
like image measurements for time series
or for not even for time series for geo
things which I agree seems a little
strange
okay but so what other cases do we need
something that projects from this time
series you get out the time series or
you could replace that Time series by an
entity that implicitly disgorges the
time series
I I think the time Series team is
developing a Time scene in select so
this could be something like select the
element of largest area or something
like that
okay or maybe you see be some time
series Maps I assume Max already works
on time series but they would be like a
maximal buy online time series right but
the problem is that what what we're
wanting is something where
directly within Jill with NQ
you are asking for this maximum extent
see what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to make sure that it's a Level Playing
Field between you just gorged out the
time series and then wanted to look at
this variant on it versus you had that
coming straight from the entity
right
so the one other I think I think that
makes sense by the way what one other uh
one other question in terms of you know
having the Geo variants behave the same
as the discouraged time series is uh can
time series deal with like infinite
future
because if you had something like you
know Eiffel Tower where it has you know
end date presumably the time series
version of that would need an infinite
future
and the next time we do one of these
meetings we need time service people
here
um let's see whether there's anything
else we can cover
um
uh
oh Francisco hasn't stacked tons let me
just pull this in
um
what the heck that's pretty non-trivial
piece of code but this is going to give
us the space-time Roman Empire
yeah that's that's the idea
or at least the space-time Roman
Republic
it's not exactly a truly a piece of code
um
wow
that's cool
that's pretty cool
and that's those are our actual polygons
those are not or are those your
samplings those are the polygons those
are all the polygons we have for the
Roman Republic yes right so it's
actually ignoring the time it's not
ignoring the time but it's sorting them
in the right order so we can make this
okay so by putting more ribbing what we
could do is put those at their times I
think it would be actually nice to see
this just for the hell of it because I
think this is the
um I mean it's not completely obvious we
shouldn't have the ability to generate
these they're kind of interesting
um
yeah so so the the space between each
one right now is fixed but it could be
the time exactly but then you could put
ribbing on the outside to join these up
so that you so that this thing is a blob
in space-time
right that's a kind of complicated Geo
operation I think but yeah
right but I mean this is so what we're
asking is
you know
in general gosh this is complicated I
mean we have
I mean my question would be if we were
able to produce these space-time regions
in principle would our region
functionality be able to resolve all
questions about was this within this one
did this have a tentacle hanging out of
this one did they overlap all those
kinds of things are those questions
actually answerable
given that we have these regions are
they is it answerable that way
we could try to answer all the questions
the problem is the syntax
let me say my thing again okay let's
assume we converted this to a
four-dimensional region
okay
do you know if our existing region
functionality
would work would answer all the
questions we want to answer
do you understand what I'm my guess is
theoretically yes like the real you know
region within region member you know
region within stuff like that would
region disjoint Q my guess is that for
the regions
um I think a lot of those do I don't
think I've ever tried it but a lot of
the more basic operations like that do
certainly things like you know region
intersection and so on I you know don't
right okay but I mean my point is that
that will be a base a ground truth that
we can start from
we understand we don't know how to
specify all of this but let's say we
could return let's say we had a property
of Roman Republic which was the 4D
space-time region
it doesn't need to be 4D because
actually coordinates are two
elements oh yeah yeah you're right it's
related I'm I was confused so definitely
our region functionality will be able to
do this
so I mean the the ground truth giving up
a prediction of course right what's that
given a projection yes
and that's a little bit funky but but I
mean in principle every question that we
could ask here every different within
intersecting blah blah blah blah we
could answer with our region
functionality from that
and I think that's a useful thing to
understand that we can have a you know
because that takes a certain amount of
pressure off the more obscure geometric
questions
if we provide people this Escape valve
where you can just use generic region
functionality for it
although the projection problem does
seem pretty serious
but I think they should go with vertical
sites so we don't try to interpolate
interpolating here is basically hopeless
because we would have to define a
mapping of points of the boundary to the
points of the boundary in the next step
that might be topological changes it is
very difficult
right
but if we if we declare that there are
only vertical
sites so things are flat yes
it can be done
right they should be flat within the
span of each polygon of course yeah and
that's how we are considering them in
all this uh your functionality with time
yep yep
so so they are discrete changes between
each polygon yeah
okay
so
um
okay we we're running out of time here
for today we need to continue this
um
can we try to continue this fairly soon
before we've all forgotten how this
works
um are there decisions that we need to
make so that you guys can move forward
on some things
I mean we're not going to get the full
solution here this is going to require
more thought
I think that
um
you know to me
obviously these things should be
available as properties of the
historical country entities this kind of
approach Where We Are
you know able to
sort of insert them as Geo variants
seems non-trivial to me
I I think one of the decisions we need
to make is you want to pursue the the
having the separate uh temporal entities
uh kind of functions or not
the ones at the end I don't know
I
I don't know I mean I think I think
we've got this notion
look that's a different thing that we
want to ask look that particular
question
I see
so that's the analog of Geo entities
right that's asking for this time axis
yeah
right but so so we could do this for
buildings as well we could say exactly
yes
I believe there's even an an example
below about
um interventions for example
right this
I suppose yet this but well I like this
concept I mean I don't know about that
Alan has something to say about this
concept because this is
oh I I think I think this is worth
pursuing I mean I I also kind of have
questions I don't know if you guys have
thought about what the syntax would be
or how we would do lookups on things
like kind of reverse lookups
right because there is some intersection
with the reverse lookups of entities for
example at least for your for these
temporal entities or
data entities because you can have a
reversal starting after this
date before this other date but for for
example for nearest there is no way to
do that with the current Entity
Framework
so you cannot search which are the
closest to this date
right
so isn't there really a place called
galassia as opposed to Galicia
sorry that's irrelevant but anyway never
mind
um sorry please continue
um
right so so one question was if we want
to follow this path also of adding
time only functions right
yeah why are some of these dynasties
with a lowercase D and others with a
capital D
plate
and Republic of Roads wisely of
capitalized hey there's some there's
some um may not needed what's that yes
okay
um
and I don't even understand whether this
is like intersecting with minus 100 or
whether this is
yeah I mean this clearly seems
worthwhile but but I mean then then I
don't understand what what happens if
you want do these things fit in the
space-time box of this and this in other
words was it between
19 you know okay I want sub-Saharan
African countries that existed between
1950 and 1970.
so then I need a box in space and time
uh yes that kind of thing could be done
with the support we did on Geo entities
using dated uh geographic region and uh
and types I understand but to me that
seems I mean okay so we've got three
cases then we've got Geo entities we've
got sort of time-bounded Geo entities
using dated
and then we've got
dated bounded entities irrespective of
Geo
right and and to me it's a little bit
inelegant that the Geo entities have
this sort of have the sort of tentacle
using dated to restrict them in time and
then we've got a whole different thing
restricting in time
right that's why we discussed a a
possible way of you know mixing these
sort of functions with the Geo functions
to make well
the to make everything I understand that
but you but you haven't given the third
case of space-time restricted
no the the space time right we haven't
defined that as a different set of
functions right now we are
doing that with the current Geo
functions
right I mean I I do think I mean I hate
to sound sort of I don't know I mean
Jose you know in the end as we do all
this Astro stuff we're going to end up
having to deal with space-time
somehow and I mean we're going to I
think you know dancing around pretending
we're not dealing with it
in the end we're gonna have to deal with
it just as we've dealt with you know
intervals and Time regions in space
you know we're going to end up with a
collection of functions for space-time I
think but but I think maybe the issue
here is that so we already have a
generic time thing which is time series
we're taking anything and projecting
into time and if we had a specific
space-time functionality then you know
well then the question is is it is it
euclidean space is it Geo
pseudospherical space is it Astro
spherical space you know it's gonna just
evolve into this whole same set of
functions
possibly you're right but possibly what
we need is a wrapper that says I mean
look the fact is putting Geo polygons
into a Time series is not necessarily A
trivial Act because time series wasn't
really built for that originally
I mean I I'm even horrified by thinking
about if you think about time series in
the Astro case Jose it's going to get
really horrifying because let's say you
put
a um
let's say you put into time series A
position on a moon of
Jupiter or something
how the heck does that work I mean the
thing is moving around it's
you know
right so so my idea there is that the
aster functions will be able to handle
those things by themselves but users
will always be able to construct data
put it in a Time series and then do
whatever they want to do additionally
because time series will have new
functions and and the Android is working
on a new concept of Time series which
will be extended and more powerful
so the possibility will always be there
to convert into time series but it's not
going to be the basis of how awesome so
just to get give me a sense of this I
mean so in you know like
in principle
we could ask the question
I mean although this is a crazy question
in Galactic coordinates
where did the Roman Empire Trace out in
Galactic coordinates
no
the
the Earth is going around the sun the
Sun is going around the center of the
Galaxy et cetera et cetera et cetera
um you know this traced out a particular
position
yes so so this goes into astronaut but
in Astro we also have Points events and
World lines and for example when we do
as we were doing a couple of days ago
observe Mars from this point this point
is an event Mars is award line so we are
Computing internally the intersection of
the award line with the light rays
emitted
um towards the past from this position
yeah so the computation is there it says
that we are not exposing it yet because
we don't have a concept of wordline and
what I will call in the future or I
would call in the future Astro orbit
that that okay but the point is
you know the Eiffel Tower is a world
line too yep and and that's what we're
realizing is that we have essentially
the same type of issue although it's not
as elaborator World line as
um you know some of these ones for
moving astronomical bodies
because we're assuming the coordinate
system is fixed for the Eiffel Tower I
mean it's the okay here's an example for
example a plane that's flying that makes
a Geo trajectory that's absolutely a
world line exactly that's another
concept that we started but we haven't
completed because of this type of
problem
which type of problem how to combine
space and time so this project we are
reviewing today is kind of from the
Forefront of these right but but the the
point that I'm making is I think we've
got to bite the bullets and just decide
we're going to go to space-time because
I think I think you know any of these
things where we're hacking around it
with you know dated Geo entities and
things like that eventually it's all
going to crumble
I will be better off just you know
defining starting off from a ground
truth that is a genuine space-time
presentation and then maybe slicing off
pieces that are simpler now I think
Christopher's point about what the heck
do we do about the spatial coordinate
systems I mean what have you done in the
astral case for that you must have
addressed that in the Astro case
yes so the all these okay
so how this works is that we have a word
line
which defines like the origin of a frame
and then we have a notion of of three
axes around that word line which Define
the orientation spatially and with that
that's enough
that's what that's why all the time we
are have to we have to say in Astro I'm
looking from Mars from the center of
Mars and I'm using equatorial
coordinates
okay defines a world line and the
quarterly coordinates the orientation
okay so do you think the same thing will
work here so in other words in in um you
know what Francisco Drew here where he's
just got these flat
pieces you believe that same Extrusion
by World line
you know looking from whatever
inequatorial coordinates or whatever
that that same thing could be executed
here
Yes actually here it's easier because do
we always use the same coordinates which
are
um
Horizon based right they're North East
up
okay so you don't think there's a
problem in extruding to space-time of
Geo data
no there is no problem and effectively
this is what they are doing in the
competition it's just that I don't think
we want to use that terminology
to do yeah I understand that I
understand that but I my prediction is
that for us to understand it and not get
confused we're going to be best off
starting from the albeit rather fancy
sounding you know space-time formulation
of the whole thing and that then we can
you know after we understand that and
after we understand that what we're
really asking is
you know I I don't completely know
okay
my claim is they're going to be cases
where you really want the whole
space-time question answered of
intersection between these space-time
regions
they're also going to be most cases
where you couldn't care less about that
and where you are looking at and that's
possibly what you know
Cesars Geo variants here are really
about that there are really three
projections that you actually care about
most of the time and we'll just give
those names and that will all be fine
but there'll be a ground truth
underneath that is based on the full
space-time picture
that's my feeling about how the design
should work
um
right and that way we know what these
projections you know we can Define this
is a projection in this way with respect
to the underlying space-time object
um
so we have to emphasize that in this
context the speed of a light would be
infinite what's that the speed of light
is irrelevant we're not worrying about
the speed of light the
um except deeply implicitly through the
fact that time and um yeah anyway never
mind
um
right I mean the we're using
we're using a static view of space-time
there are no
um it's merely uh uh yeah I don't even
know I think speed of light has gone to
Infinity probably for our purposes here
yeah
um okay I need to go to a different
meeting here um which I think is also
being live stream another design review
um can we try and bring this back please
within the next week and maybe you guys
can have a think about what the kind of
space-time ground truth might look like
um
sound reasonable
okay okay
this is very nice functionality not a
moment too soon
after we see our notes from 2018 and so
on
and uh
um yeah good stuff all right see you
guys soon